el resorte está comprimido el doble de
alta x2 d se le pide al estudiante
indicar si la posición final del bloque
será el doble de la distancia x 6 de el
estudiante razona que ya que el resorte
está comprimido el doble de lo que
estaba antes el bloque tendrá más
energía cuando deje el resorte por lo
que llegará más lejos en el camino antes
de detenerse en la posición x igual a 6
d recordemos que es lo que se le propuso
al estudiante en la primera versión del
argumento se comprimió el resorte una
distancia de el resorte al descomprimir
se acelerará el bloque y justo cuando
regresa a x0 toda esa energía potencial
se transforma en energía cinética y
luego la fricción actúa en sentido
contrario al movimiento del bloque por
lo que podemos verlo como que
proporciona trabajo negativo ya que la
dirección de esta fuerza es contraria a
nuestro cambio en x el trabajo negativo
eventualmente ocasiona que el bloque se
detenga y ahora
toda la energía cinética se ha
transformado en calor el bloque llega a
tres de ahora el nuevo argumento que
llamaremos argumento 2 vamos a comprimir
el resorte el doble de la distancia y lo
que propone el estudiante es que si el
resorte se comprime el doble entonces
tendrá mayor energía potencial
almacenada porque se requiere más
trabajo para comprimir el resorte el
doble de la distancia y esta mayor
energía potencial se transforma en mayor
energía cinética cuando regresemos a x0
por lo que no sólo llegaremos más lejos
él dice que llegaremos el doble de lejos
así que en lugar de llegar a 3 d
ahora vamos a llegar a 6 de ahora veamos
lo que nos preguntan aquí pero antes
pongamos signos de interrogación aquí
puedes no sé si esto sea verdad cuáles
aspectos si es que hay alguno del
razonamiento del estudiante son
correctos explica tu respuesta doble y
cuáles aspectos si es que hay alguno del
razonamiento del estudiante son
incorrectos explica tu respuesta
el estudiante tiene razón en cuanto a
que comprimir
comprimir más
el resorte comprimir más el resorte
resultará en mayor energía en mayor
energía cuando el bloque
cuando el bloque deje el resorte
lo que resultará en que el bloque
llegará más lejos lo que resultará en
que el bloque llegará más lejos
cuáles aspectos si es que hay alguno del
razonamiento del estudiante son
incorrectos explica tu respuesta
el comprimir el resorte el comprimir el
resorte al doble
el resorte al doble
no resulta
en el doble
no resulta en el doble de la distancia
a la que se detiene el bloque
y podríamos explicar más esto si
quisiéramos sabemos que la energía
potencial 1 es igual a un medio porque
la constante del resorte porque tanto
comprimimos el resorte al cuadrado por
lo que podemos decir que la energía
la energía crece
la energía crece con el cuadrado
con el cuadrado de que tanto comprimimos
el resorte de que tanto comprimimos el
resorte
dos veces la compresión resultarán dos
veces la compresión resultará en cuatro
veces la energía en cuatro veces la
energía
lo que a su vez resultará en cuatro
veces cuatro veces la distancia
la distancia a la que se detiene el
bloque
a la que se detiene el bloque creo que
hicimos un buen trabajo al explicar en
qué tiene razón el estudiante y en donde
su razonamiento es incorrecto